[Music]
please don't get involved
what is it labor day yep
labor day
i do not uh acknowledge this holiday
here at thick boy there's a few holidays
i do this is not one of them
um
monday's holiday holds a much deeper
mean room 19th century fight for fair
working conditions yep but it's 2022 now
so most people work from home so days
off
you have enough days off what are you
what are you teachers
you know what i'm saying you should be
more compensated but
more days off my kid has way too many
days off they've been making [ __ ] about
star wars thursday
this is the day star wars came out we'd
like to acknowledge that and honor star
wars
it's may the fourth yeah maybe the
fourth they take may the fourth off oh
it's happy gilmore wednesday we're big
adam sandler fans we're going to take
wednesday off every [ __ ]
july 9th or whatever you're like all
right you're just making [ __ ] up now to
get days off
yeah i mean
labor it was 2022 most people work from
home and if that's coming twice a week
they complain so
you're not here you know
i mean if you listen i'm hr if you have
complaints about the holidays submit
your holiday one-off and i'll get back
to you okay christmas you got it daddy
it's christmas come on i'm not the
cringe i'm not scrooge you don't have to
work on christmas
outside that we're working here
and by working i mean we'll shoot to two
and then you have the rest of the
afternoon off all right
great grand wonderful fresh off the
plane from austin texas
visiting my friend joseph rogan who's
the official governor of uh texas now so
yeah that's cool he's just told me he's
governor now so that's pretty cool um
it was such a good time and brian's here
could not look grayer and his he's
completely gray right he's completely
great he looks super great therefore
he'd say it's delighting but it's your
life right it's just how he looks these
days look at jamie yeah
jamie's actually in shape but yeah you
know all of us looked like uh father
time slapped us in the face with his
dick that's what we've all we haven't
done this in quite some time we're all a
lot everyone's a lot grayer a lot
thicker some good thick some aren't bad
thick i don't want to go through
everybody and then uh you know
father time slapped us with his big wet
dick in the face and a lot of guys are
gray
rogan's 55 in better shape than
everybody in that picture so that's cool
but he's a he's the governor of texas
it was a good time man that's it i mean
it's just the easiest it's just a weird
chemistry thing like when the four of us
get together it's so cool that you guys
brought it back yeah it's so fun we'll
do we're planning to do some more too oh
yeah forget how fun it is it was so fun
man
so so fun uh barely watched any of the
fights but uh
you know we watched the i'd say we
watched
most of the co-main event in the main
event for ufc france uh we'll go through
that really quick and then we'll cover
because you get the big ufc pay-per-view
this weekend you got nate diaz versus
hamzat which we'll get to
um just to recap
what we covered on fight campaign with
uh ufc paris you know in the main event
you had uh cyril gone and tai to avasa
you know didn't disappoint and uh i
don't think anybody loses value and uh i
think sarah gans value goes up for
getting a finish and he did look
fantastic you know
because sir gone again you gotta
remember he's only been fighting for
four years mixed martial arts four years
and he's the number one number two guy
in the world so he's pretty freaking
talented he's going to get better over
time
but you know the knock on him is he can
be a little boring to sit back and just
pick guys apart if they don't take
chances that you know he'll ride out a
decision but when guys do take chances
like tai tuavasa or other gentlemen you
get a fight on your hands and tai tu
avas is the perfect dance partner to
bring the excitement out of cyril gone
and again i don't think the stock on tai
tu havasu goes down if anything it goes
up how fun is he how can he not root him
thank you sir happy holiday happy
happy [ __ ] we're over everybody
here's happy we're overworked even
though we work from home day okay
jesus christ
um cheers everybody
but uh you know i thought taito have
also brought it is he fought how we
thought he was going to fight i also
think he
you know even to my um
from my perspective he also showed he
deserves to be there he's a top caliber
heavyweight you know he didn't just go
in there and brawl he didn't go and then
just make it a dogfight and close the
gap and you know take hits coming in he
used his footwork had some really good
leg kicks i thought like kicks were
there even more if he wanted um you know
and he did knock zero gun down to to his
ass which before he got ko that was the
biggest moment in the fight i thought he
was going to finish him because you did
the one of the best things about tai
tuvasa if he hurts you man it's on he
smells blowing that water he's going to
get you out of there just shows you at
the caliber sierra gone is because he
got dropped man first time ever wobble
bad and you know he's not easy got a hit
you look at his uh pedigree you look at
his track record like you know a lot of
jds couldn't do it rosenstru there's a
lot of guys he couldn't do that to him
and tai toovasa world-class man he's a
world-class fighter
straight up world-class i mean look
volkov couldn't do that to him derek
lewis and these are all you know these
guys are known for their striking so
yeah junior dos santos when the best
ever do it granted longer in the tooth
by longer i mean all the long long on
the tooth uh rosen strute good striker
volk glove good striker dick lewis good
striker francis obviously just grappled
him to even you know strike with him and
then he got tied to avasa so they give
him fights to make it exciting um but he
has to guys have to take chances when
they do
he has the talent to [ __ ] yet man again
he's only been fighting mixed martials
for four years remember that so he's
getting a lot better he's probably the
future of the division
i just don't know you know he's in a
weird spot even though this is a huge
win for him he's in a weird spot because
you look at the heavyweight division
there's this
tall
looming monster shadow just hanging over
the division just waiting to jump in his
name's jon jones and that's the money
fight that's the marquee fight that's
the fight the ufc's waiting on and it's
you know it's even though sirogon's
ranked number one um it's jon jones
division even though france is champ
it's jon jones division it's he's going
to dictate what happens uh for sheryl
ghan's career for stipe's career for
francis's career so it all comes down to
one guy and it's jon jones that's how
talented jon jones is so we're just
waiting for it you know he's just
looming in the shadows waiting for them
to send him a contract because
from what i've heard he's ready to go
it's the other guy's not ready to go
it's a steep bay not ready to go it's uh
you know some of the other guys aren't
ready to go clearly francis isn't ready
to go so i think you're gonna get uh a
steep bay announcement uh end of
december i think they close out that big
card december you get a jon jones steep
where that fights
francis if france decides to go that
route
i feel like some of the
goss
some of the hype around francis versus
tyson fury is over i feel like that
ship's kind of set sail a little bit i
think francis getting injured being out
for so long fury talking about
retirement but now fury's calling out
usyk
so you know fury's in he's out he's in
he's out fury's not really mentioning
francis
so if you're francis it's kind of a
scary road
you could leave the ufc but let's say in
this crazy fight world that we live in
you don't get that tyson fury fight
where
do you plan on making the most you know
where you gonna make the most money and
fight the biggest guys and get the most
fame
you know one championship not doesn't
have a heavy you know roster as far as
heavyweights go you could be the king
over there um depending on the contracts
the guarantees they give you might make
more money you know um
but really when it comes to boxing he
did say you know my me taking a
professional boxing fight or few fights
isn't predicated on tyson fury it's like
well i do think there's a world where if
tyson fury for whatever reason let's say
he fights usic and they do that whatever
two or three more times
tyson isn't going to throw into francis
in the
mix as he's fighting an usyk or joshua
or deontay wilder that that or andy ruiz
you know which we'll get to fought this
past weekend
so
for tyson
like this is kind of uh
it's uh
you know
i don't say it's a circus it's not
because francis is the best heavyweight
in the world right now um
so you know it's not a circus fight but
it is you know
um
it's kind of a
a dessert
if you want to call it for from his you
know from his main entree you know his
main entree has been the best box in the
world which he is and in order to do
that he has to focus on guys like usyk
even though i thought he was retired so
the the the
the france fight made a lot more sense
but sounds like he does want to take his
shots at usyk which is the toughest
fight possible for tyson fury even
though titus free is a lot bigger but
you know as far as technique wise goes
career-wise uh usa is a bad
ukrainian he is a bad [ __ ] even
though he's undersized only at 220 that
dude is no joke
so for francis i think when he says it's
just not predicated on tyson fury i
think that's smart because
you could get i think maybe a joshua
fight or a wilder fight
i think they would entertain it you know
especially joshua coming off these two
losses it's kind of no man's land but
again if guys are gonna decide to do
this it takes him out of
this rat race in the heavyweight
division boxing because you you don't
want to get sidetracked with this and
then try to get back into the mix
because you know the heavyweight
division is really you got
you look at it you got deante wilder
who's coming back fights soon and he'll
fight uh
andy ruiz if he wins because andy ruiz
just won last night against uh ortiz
which was i thought it was a fun fight
you dude andy ruiz has no business being
that thick and that fast it is insane
dude the tattoos were 30 for a loop but
man that boy is
stupid thick you know what i'm saying so
you got andy ruiz deonte wilder usyk
fury joshua kind of a five man
you know horse there so
if you're gonna entertain a francis
fight that kind of takes you out of that
race you know and i think most of those
guys are in that race and balls deep
into that race unless deonte water were
to get upset unless andy ruiz were to
get upset then one of those guys might
entertain a francis fight but in general
i think france would be waiting a little
bit and by a little bit i mean at least
a year year and a half maybe two years
to get one of those big cash
cows let's take a little break from me
chatting your hair off about the fight
game outputs in wisconsin you're up this
thursday friday saturday appleton
wisconsin this freaking week think boy
tour in september starts with you in
appleton wisconsin then right after that
next week ontario california ontario
improv on my favorite clubs september
15th to the 17th that's a thursday
through saturday then i end september's
tour dates in boston
favorite city boston i'm coming thursday
friday saturday that bad boy almost sold
out and then canada got a little
surprise for you coming soon on out soon
canada is coming up in october haven't
been the hot second but appleton
wisconsin you're up this week tickets at
thickboy.com get you some football fans
the first sunday the nfl season is here
and your boy is stoked on it
my bronco's gonna be good this year baby
we got russell wilson also the la rams
the la chargers it's a good time to be a
football fan but listen it's a good time
to watch the nfl and make bank bro with
draftking sports book they are an
official sports band partner the nfl and
they're giving new customers a can't
miss offer to celebrate
the return of the nfl season right now
new customers can bet just five dollars
and get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly and as an added bonus for week
one everyone can experience the thrill
of draftkings early win promotion it's
simple bet on an nfl team to win if your
team leads by 10 at any point during the
game you get paid instantly even if they
lose the game if they get up at 10 point
whether the first quarter second quarter
third quarter fourth quarter they win
lose doesn't matter you get paid if they
get up 10 all right mma fans don't
forget too there's a big ufc 279
this freaking saturday you have freaking
hamza nate diaz there's so many parlays
you can do on that i think nate diaz is
gonna win you can make some money on
that he's plus 675 i think he's if he
does win it's after the third round so
you can bet on those prop bets like nate
diaz winning tko submission past three
rounds there's all sorts of fun stuff do
on there yeah nfl ufc make bank with
draftkings download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
shop show sch aub show to get 200 in
free bets instantly when you place a
five dollar bet this sunday that's coach
shaw show only a draftking sportsbook an
official sportszone partner in the nfl
minimum age eligibility restriction
supplies see show notes for details see
next page for directions of disclaimer
again download draftking's sportsbook
app right now use promo code shop show
man you guys like to make fun of me
because i don't have the wireless
earbuds in my ear all the time when i'm
riding my bike or i'm br i'm jogging
that's because they don't fit my ears
man i've never found one that fits in my
ears and then i got a little gift from
raycon wireless earbuds and i went whoa
not only things fit but they sound
fantastic it's the only earbud i use
because the only earbud that fits my ear
it comes with different freaking perfect
in-air fits
optimized gel tips baby that's right ray
cons i swear by them i love them they
look they feel they sound better than
ever they give you eight hours of play
time 32 hour battery life which is
priceless baby you get quality auto at
half the price of other premium audio
brands it's no wonder raycon's everyday
earbuds have over 50 000 5 star reviews
all right it's noise isolation they got
an awareness mode they get all sorts of
stuff i again my ears are weird look it
looks like a tortellini they fit my air
they don't fall out they're fantastic go
to buy raycon dot com shop s-h-a-b today
get 15 off your raycon order that's by
r-a-y-c-o-n dot com shop to score
fifteen percent off by raycon dot com
shop so if you're his team you got to
sit down and go all right as far as mma
goes where is the best fit for us i do
think it's the ufc um as far as boxing
goes that's going to be it's give me a
little bit of a wait to get one of those
big you know golden gooses obviously
fury's the number one golden goose
especially uh usake so if you beat zoo
sig there's nothing really left form
that's the best case for uh francis
but you know they wouldn't fight to
probably early next year mid next year
and then then you talk about a france
fight if you do it right with the
promotion you're looking at a late fight
of 2023
you know so for francis yeah there's big
money being made out there in boxing but
boxing especially at the heavier
division is popping right now and those
guys want to you know focus on boxing so
i think the loser in all that would be
francis
so
and also sarah gone because
france has decided what he wants to do
but i do think what's going to help kind
of motivate francis is if jon fights
stipe in december and john absolutely
annihilates him and goes i'm the best
heavyweight in the world there's no
doubt about it francis if you're scared
i get it go fight somewhere else but if
not i'm your huckleberry
that could get francis just resign with
ufc and and and get that big marquee
fight so if you get john takes out steep
bay it's a big f but
odds are he will and then the build-up
of francis john would be nutsos notzos
not those
and it'd be cool if the ufc played ball
where they tell francis dude re-sign
with us for a six-fight deal right so we
get these crazy fights album with john
and sarah gone again because i would
like to see him for sure gone at full
health so if you get serogon francis you
got john there you go curtis blades even
though you know i know he lost him but
you know different guy right now so
it'd be cool if the ufc went we'll sign
you a six fight deal and we'll let you
box like we did conor
that'd be best case scenario hopefully
they do that but uh for cheryl ghan yeah
it's
for him next
you know
probably curtis blades
pavlich is a problem tom askball is out
a hot second derrick looks on losing
streak vocabulary in the street grocery
losing streak
you know those those top five are you
know and i would say top six but that's
when i was out with the the leg injury
for a hot second so
he he had been a good one uh for
chirogun
but uh
yeah so you've got taito avasta you've
got steve bay at sergan chris blades
francis you know it's stacked and they
got john just looming over everybody
so
it's really interesting what they do but
a cyril gone chris blades uh match could
could make a lot of sense though
because outside that i mean a pavlich
right there you know but no now the big
dogs you know and then astronauts
injured
every division is popping right now
especially top six it's fun and john if
john comes back so fun
so fun can't wait he's coming back
guarantee it december
um
the co-main event you had uh this should
have been a five-round fight you had
robert whitaker marvin matory
man
robert whittaker definitely had um a
speed advantage in this i thought
vittori
when he was going forward and pressuring
him even though he's getting hit that
was the move but at some point you know
the gas tank maybe a little bit of the
pressure and he backed off that's when
robert whittaker started to land then
after that it was kind of
you know the blueprint for robert
whitaker don't let vittori be first
don't let victoria pressure you and he
just went to work then robert whittaker
proved why he's you know the best
middleweight in the world outside of
izzy
um you know unfortunately just can't
really beat izzy
and for izzy again the
middleweight and heavyweight's so
interesting because
for
izzy right he fights pierre soon here
for izzy pierra stylosky is a tough
matchup right because they're both
strikers and he beat him previously in
glory and stuff like that everyone wants
to you know
focus on that but if you go back and
watch that fight if he's actually won
that fight the entire time until he got
kind of rocked there but um
you know if izzy gets past pierra
i i don't know i don't
you're just gonna chill around and to
rogan's point uh we talked about in the
fight campaign he goes just stick around
and and be the guy to just dominate be
the best middleweight of all time just
dominate everybody oh my god
in the new age of the ufc it's these
guys they want more they want to be you
know double champs and they want to move
up and go for the big money and become
two title holders and stuff like that so
i i just i don't know
i don't know so
um
for izzy to jump to light heavyweight
especially if you know yawn loses his
next fight so he doesn't have to worry
about a yawn a big grappler like a
glover who can really grapple so for
izzy to go up there and fight gear or
something like that i think makes a lot
of sense
and for him can he stay at that level
and stay motivated i guess like john did
john that light heavyweight
just dominated everybody but there was
also a lot of big names and he'd have to
keep him over and over granted he fought
justin twice fought dc twice you know
but there's a lot of superstars a lot of
a lot of meat for him you know if he's
t-rex there's a lot of sheep for him to
eat alive in that cage so
for his he could do that i think you
know it's a motivational thing are you
motivated to fight robert whittaker a
third time even though you're 2-0 you
know if victoria won where are you
motivated to fight victoria a third time
even though you've won both times you
know so
now if pierre wins the division's
interesting because obviously you get a
rematch with izzy but also izzy is by
far the best match up for him because
everybody else in that division can
wrestle that'd be a problem for pierre
and it's gonna be a short career at the
top
but if you just buy izzy you know we
going sizzler
so it's interesting man
the ufc could be chaos
ufc could be straight chaos and that
leads us to this
main event of the pay-per-view this
weekend which is ufc 279
pure chaos you have nate diaz
versus hamzat which in most
oddsmakers eyes
fans eyes
ufc brass eyes besides dana even though
he's you know playing damage control
this is a straight slaughter fest you
know you have hamzad at a surging uh
minus two minus yeah what was he minus
twenty two hundred dollars
minus eleven fifty and the only reason
that's even minus eleven fifty because
the straight crazed fan base of nate
diaz put a lot of money on nate so it
fluctuates you know but if you got it at
the jump you know he was a minus 2200.
well i think when he first came in mice
2400 so that's insane in the ufc
but when you talk about chaos
straight chaos what if nate diaz wins
he very well could it's mma man never
put it past the guy now i'll tell you
how
it should work if the world's normal if
the if we're not living an alternate
reality how it should work
and that's why he's a minus [ __ ] 1700
i'll tell you how it should work the way
it should work is hamzad
gets them out there in under two rounds
and it's a complete [ __ ] bully beat
down
so he
uh he's won one fight um since 2016.
that'd be six years he'd be anthony
pettis
and then
before that he beat um
conor mcgregor in 2016. they lost conor
in the rematch on 16 right and then in
2019 he won against antiparesi lester
jorge that was really bad and then he
lost to leon edwards not the best so you
know in the most recent fights 2019
which isn't that recent three years ago
and then leon edwards his most recent
which is june of last year so about a
year and change you know year in two
months um you know that leon edwards
fight kids was not close
i know the media you know nate landed a
one punch at the end there but that
fight in general was not close now
he did go against the champ leonardo was
the current champ
and uh that fight was
staged for land edwards to beat the [ __ ]
out of him and then leonardo goes on to
fight for a title but you know that
fight unfortunately for leon edwards
didn't go the way he wanted to
in the last 30 seconds they got clipped
that was the narrative that was the
story the nadia's fan base runs with it
the marketing behind it the publicity
it's all about nate not leon [ __ ] leon
over
but if you go back and watch that fight
it wasn't very competitive in the fight
before that in 2019 against jorge
mazwell not very competitive there's
some ten eight rounds there he had
annihilated by jorge masvidal beats
anthony pettis right but again that's
you look at 2019 so
again if you go through just very black
and white no
do i like the guy do i not like the guy
just being on outside perspective as the
if i was an analyst quote unquote you
would look at this and go oh this is a
terrible matchup for nate diaz he's
gonna get absolutely annihilated
um
you know nate's best chance
i think is on the feet with his volume
punching and wearing hamzad out because
remember
hamzat
in the in the gilbert burns fight where
we saw him look human and he looked very
human he got rocked lost that second
round came back weather storm won the
third round dug deep um
you know this is five rounds this is a
five round fight nate diaz gets better
after three his his cardio and
everything is better after the third
round so those championship rounds
could be where nate diaz flourishes man
you know so if you pick nate to win the
fourth fifth round it's not a terrible
bet tko in the fourth or fifth round um
or unless he were to hamzat exhausted
from punching eighties in the face
and uh decides to take nate down they
just have the capability to submit homs
on
early on though if you guys are banking
on nate going good luck with uh nate
diaz on the ground
cool early on while hamza is not sweaty
and he has energy
his advantage is on the feet and the
ground he's going to molly he's going to
rag dalton ideas around that octagon
he's going to take him down whenever he
wants and that ground and pound and his
his style of grappling is the exact
opposite of nate diaz he does not play a
traditional jiu jitsu game it's a very
dagger standing uh chechnyan
break you at all cause style and that is
a nightmare for a traditional jiu jitsu
guy a nightmare a [ __ ] nightmare so
if hamzad is as good as we think he is
and we're living in reality in 2022
hamza should absolutely mop the floor
with nate diaz
but all that being said
the world is weird some people think
it's flat some people think
certain things aren't real there's a lot
of misinformation a lot of fake news out
there there's a whole agenda with the
government there's all sorts of weird
stuff right
who freaking there's so many ways to
lose in the ufc who knows how hamzap
feels being this big of a favorite did
hamzat learn from the gilbert burns
fight does his team tighten things up is
he going to stick to the game plan or is
he going to go oh nate d you know
because trust me nathan's going to flip
him off and there's me in his face he i
i in my head i picture nate diaz bloody
flipping him off getting in his face
hamza doesn't have a ton of experience
does that get hamza out of his
professional game plan and he starts to
play that game with nate because then
the odds start to favor nate a little
bit in that you know because hamza did
that against gilbert burns and gilbert
burns is nowhere near the caliber of guy
when he comes inside that octane that
pulls those shenanigans they'll lure you
in they'll talk all this [ __ ] and get
you out of your out of your mental space
next thing you know you're like why am i
trading with this guy and that's what he
wants and for nate the longest fight
goes the better so if hamza doesn't get
done by the third round you and you put
your entire you know kids college
tuition on homsat you're gonna be your
[ __ ] is gonna be this [ __ ] tight
because the longer this fight goes the
better is for nate diaz
but again
and i'm not betting on the fight and if
i where i put money on nate ideas
because i want to make money the chance
of you know making money on honda you
put so much up it's not it's not even
worth it
so if you want to make money it's it's
nate diaz going past three rounds
winning you know uh via submission or
tko in the fourth fifth round he ain't
doing in the first or second um that's
too much of tidal wave too young too
ambitious
i i would assume the camp he comes from
he's going to stick to a game plan and
this should be an absolute beat down
that being and that's why there's so
much backlash that's why there's so much
backlash um to the show my son keeps
facetime let me see you can keep playing
it let's see what he wants
what's up dude
what's up buddy
i'm at work pal what are you doing
[Music]
no no
mike or
mike or mark mark's here or what do you
mean you mean like mike stud
oh big mike
yeah big mike's here
no yeah mike's dead no he's mike stud is
not here
nope he doesn't work here buddy he's
making music
[Music]
nope he's a musician
that's why we listen on the radio pal
when we drive to malibu
mike is
i thinking mark
mark's right there dude there's uncle
mark
t let me uh knock this shot buddy and
then we'll go to that malibu cookoff
okay
all righty i love you buddy let me get
back to work okay pal
where we go the car show out they have
this big fear they're with a bunch of
rides and stuffies and you play games
and they have a carousel and roller
coasters yeah they have stuffies there
dude
stuffies
i think so we'll find out man but yeah
let me get through this uh
show okay
all right i love you buddy i'll see you
soon
love you be nice all right be nice to
your brother love you
sorry about that
the day off labor day
days off for parents you're like [ __ ]
i mean i enjoy it because you know i
have to be on the road on thursday so i
get to spend a lot of time with them but
for regular parents days off you're like
[ __ ] we're gonna do these kids man i
enjoy it you know because i don't have a
good nine to five but for regular
parents they're like sweating bullets
like the summer's off or a beast for
preparing there's a cookout today yeah
maple uh cook-off it started on friday
it's friday saturday sunday i think
monday okay cool yeah it'll be fun
stuff he's dude huh stuffed animals he
loves stuffed animals
you know my kid doesn't yeah but i
[ __ ] up because if i get him a stuffed
family not his brother he got his
brother his brother wanted a dinosaur
i'm like dude just get the same thing as
tiger you're gonna be upset if you don't
get it he's like no i want this t-rex
i'm like alright cool get it
you're back home he's crying because
he's gonna have the same stuff as his
brother so now i gotta go back to the
goddamn store and get that same stuffy
hope they have too
dad life man dead life dad life uh back
to the [ __ ] show sorry guys hope you
enjoyed that uh so nate diaz hamzlot
it's a fascinating fight even though we
know one is a complete underdog he's the
underdog and it's nate diaz and can
never count him out and he is
as tough as they come
and he's going against this surging
chechnyan [ __ ] lion and it's
fascinating take all my money i will be
on stage in appleton when this fight's
happening um so i'll have to watch it
after the fact we will have it on the
green room so i'll be able to see what's
popping
the co-main event
again
you have another again i'm not saying
this the odds makers are saying this um
you have another mismatch in uh jinglang
and um tony ferguson and it's at 170 and
tony as you guys most of you know is
predominantly a 155 er but it's been a
tough path for him there and he's very
long in the tooth career-wise so he
decided to go up to
170. my issue with this fight is you
know lee jingling is a savage the leech
is a savage i would have liked an easier
fight for his first fight at 170. you
know but it's tony ferguson he's on an
all-time great first ballot hall of
famer um
i would have liked a different fight for
him just to get his bearings on him he's
with a new camp he's with jackson's camp
um
i know it's from experience you know i
lost
two fights in a row you start
questioning your camp and you start
questioning everything and you think
it's a camp problem and you leave you
leave that camp and you you think when
you go to new one those problems are
going to be left in wherever you know
tony was competing at uh and running his
camp before those problems follow you
wherever you go it's not a camp problem
it's a you problem and sometimes for
certain guys starting a new camp means a
new start a fresh start and you don't
feel the same kind of animosity or kind
of um
i don't say hey but there's a part of
you that you know you're like admin this
guy didn't do this for me this guy
didn't do this i could have done this he
should have done this he didn't coach me
this 30 fragrances always done his own
thing when it comes to camps now he's
with a real camp and not only he's with
the real camp he's he's with the camp
jackson so
um
for a guy like tony doesn't make a lot
of sense does he work in that structured
camp environment we'll find out but
we're finding out against a very tough
formidable opponent in the leach so
i would have liked a different fight
from again this is another you know
minus 300 for for leach and lee is
you know for co-main event
pretty big pretty high man pretty high
you know pretty high favorite so this is
another mismatch um
the best fight most
competitive fight uh stylistically
matchup wise technique wise age-wise is
kevin holland versus daniel rodriguez
that's your fight of the night
that's your friday night now
that's saying a [ __ ] ton about kevin
hall and daniel rodriguez because you
have a i'm saying friday night you also
have a tony ferguson nate diaz on the
card and those guys are so goddamn tough
that's usually what wins five of the
night when it's back and forth the guy's
so tough getting his ass what comes back
that's your fight of the night
tony ferguson and nate diaz are very
capable pulling off by the knights
dana's gonna have to get the checkbook
out for this card because
if i know tony ferguson i do you
streamline for a long time if tony
ferguson uh if if the leach thinks it's
going to be an easy fight he's gonna get
him out of there early he's out of his
[ __ ] mind tony ferguson's toughest to
come he's with new camp new belief is he
crazy sure but for his style it works
the leech is in for a long night now
does he win probably but he's in for a
long night to to take that scalp of tony
ferguson's a tough task
so
me saying kevin hall and daniel or yeah
tonight is
big big
regards for kevin hall and daniel
rodriguez
this fight's at a catchweight 180 180
because it was a short notice fight for
both fighters
i know some people like oh you know
catch weight you know does it does it
stop the
surge of whoever wins this fight no
because we know that you know at 180 and
short notice we're getting the best out
of both guys and still counts as a win
on their record and be a huge one
whoever wins that fight also whoever
wins that fight kind of goes from
pretender to contender you know
pretender to contender danny rodriguez
you know la kid tough [ __ ] guy always
brings it always you know fight of the
night is always on his mind uh he's on
three fight win streak he's also won a
ton he's lost one fight um by decision
outside that your boy's a beast
he's a beast and he's fun to watch
you know and against kevin holland it's
a great [ __ ] fight man great great
fight i'm
i would say i'm most excited for that
fight i'm most curious about the
homs.net ds fight i'm curious how tony
ferguson looks as far as
styles match up in the prime i'm more
excited for kevin hall and daniel
rodriguez than anybody on the flight
card
again johnny walker another guy bounced
around camps right he has the ak he's
trying to figure it out came out of the
gate hot had all this promise he was a
big
prospect does the worm blows his [ __ ]
shoulder out then it's a sad story he's
lost four out of his last five
he needs a win
what's interesting too is he just got
starched in the first round by jamal
hill
and that was in february
so i don't like this fight for him this
soon you should take in some more time
uh before that he lost diego santos he
beat ryan spann cool he lost krylov lest
corey anderson you know crying monster
but um
you know for johnny walker you know he
found himself at was it uh
in dublin at sb is his sbc spg yes bg so
hopefully that's the right camp for him
now he had that same camp when he fought
ryan spann you know
he had the same camp i'm sorry not right
he had that same camp when he fought uh
jamal hill
get started so
he's he's questioned himself he's a
little lost he's fun
but
um his style
at the highest level is um it's tough to
bet on it's [ __ ] tough to bet on you
know it's really tough to bet on it's
tough to bank on that guy so
um
you know this fight
no loser probably leaves
and when i say leaves i'd say you know i
don't think they cut them i mean like
as far as like being a contender those
days are over whoever lose this fight
because cute cutie libra is a monster
too fun guy um savage just fought all
comers and you know
whoever they're they're doing this for a
reason so either somebody gets cut or
um we just know it's over you know
i i would not bet on this fight i
if i had to i'd take cue to libra i just
with johnny walker he's too wild too
unorthodox
he's com once his confidence is gone
he's talking about his confidence he
just got starched
by jamal hill that's a bad knockout man
so i'm not bad i would not touch a
johnny walker fight right now i just
wouldn't
great card though but it's a great card
and there's a lot of like
man what's gonna happen there's a lot of
like
you know kind of
mystery how's nate diaz going to do
against the hamza house tony first going
to do with new camp at 170 you know
how's daniel rodriguez and kevin holland
going to do at this catch weight how's
johnny walker going to look you know
coming off that big knockout how's cute
libra going to look because whoever
loses that probably has to get out of
the [ __ ] club you know
and then the bantamweight you got uh
irene aldana versus macy
um good fight you know bantamweight
needs a contender and this could be the
next contender so that one's fun that's
probably the least exciting fight in the
card but uh those other four are barn
burners
entertaining definitely worth the money
i'm gonna pull theo vaughn here like he
does trying to get on the ufc broadcast
like dana white we don't deserve this
79.99 man i would have paid 300 for this
you know [ __ ] like that
it's fun card though man a lot of
mystery and that's what makes fighting
fun a lot of mystery
you know punk spice lattes are back baby
anyone else is back it's the seasonal
pumpkin spice you got to make sure your
crotch looks nice that means sipping
cider in fall breeze and using manscape
baby manscape products to trim your
balls with ease that's right today's
shop show is brought to you by manscape
a company here to make sure that your
bush isn't the only thing shedding its
excess leaves that's right heck even
mother nature knows it's time to lose
that extra clutter for the fall join the
6 million bros worldwide who trust
manscape by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping of the code
shob 20 that's sch aub20
whether you're brand new or already with
the manscape crew you could use the
crown jewel of care for your family
jewels with the platinum 4.0 package in
this package you get the lawnmower 4.0
you get the body trimmer all right the
weed whacker nose ear trimmer you get
the freaking uh body wash all right the
ultra premium two in one shampoo and
conditioner and you get the freaking
premium deodorant all right and then
also you have the crop preserver the
bald earn it for you the crop reviver
you also get a freaking manscape boxers
and a shed travel bag to put all your
goodies in man get the platinum package
this fall these products are guaranteed
to be a hit for your dangly bits go to
bandscape.com get 20 off and free
shipping with the code shop20 that's
sch8b20 that's swimsoft with free
shipping at manscape.com when you use
code shop20 manscape cloud the leaves
it's your tree trunks time to shine
let's get back to the program
we're not getting back to the show uh
remix curveball because listen man a lot
of people ask me what kratom to use do
you love kratom i go i don't do anything
without kratom anytime you see me doing
podcasting anytime you see me doing
stand-up i'm on the craddon baby just
not any kratom listen kratom's the wild
west like cbd about five years ago you
know who to trust you don't know what's
in the product but with my friends at
happy hippo you know exactly what's in
the product they give it to you a
variety of ways and right now they have
a big labor day sale going on so if you
go visit happy hippo herbals.com all
right that's happy hippo herbals.com
user promo code sickboy you get 20 off
for life use that code as many times you
want that's 20 for life with the promo
code sick boy kratom is fantastic kratom
is natural all right it's the best
product i've ever used happy hippo is
the best kratom i've ever used it's my
limitless pill enjoy i know you've been
out there you think about tried and try
and create them we'll do it with happy
hippo go to happyhippo herbals.com promo
code thick boy for 20 off for life now
seriously let's get back to the program
what else you got jen
oh so okay
during the finish sequence right with
cyril gone
and taiwasa you did see a one like
hammer fist to the back of the head
right i mean it's in the motion so it's
really difficult to say anything about
it but it's tough because the guy's
moving he's trying a bunch of punches
and junior santa's rips dirty fighter
junior
junior is still pissed off your back
dude
you know what i'm saying it's like you
turned your back
so this is december 2020
[Music]
you heard him back
[Music]
i mean but it's it's also because
everyone's moving it's moving also jds
is like this yeah yeah he was already he
was like hurt yeah he's already on sixth
street you can't say queer street
anymore he's on sixth street so it's
like you know
in the face
so jds did
um what a dirty fighter this gun is
again in the back of the head
nad now what are those fight experts
we'll say about it
matt nat now what i don't know what what
has to be a translation issue i know
what's up
he just shows that clip
so there's one punch for sure though
go ahead and play it there this one
that that left hook uppercut shovel
punch is what knocked him out yeah
that's a dropped him
i don't think dawn's dirty i think he
panics and that he's trying to get the
guy out there by any means necessary for
for that jds fight it's kind of like
you know think about what started that
where he
had the opportunity to hit you in the
back head granty
i agree this is too
back the head hits
it's not like he's intentionally doing
it but also you should be mad you got
punched in the face and put on sixth
street yeah for for taito vasa you
should be mad you got hit with the
shovel uppercut that knocked you out you
know those those are the issue
you saw the and real quick jadis
do you do you think the back of the head
well jd is a little different he is on
sixth street and he's like kind of out
of it and then gets in the back of the
head
but do you think god would have finished
it without that
i think so do you think you would have
finished taito vasa without that i think
so yeah are those back to the head hits
the the main thing that or the issue of
why you lost absolutely not no
absolutely not and i think i think back
then jds said like the last few punches
were in the back of the head but if you
look at it closely it looks like it was
this you know the side it's so hard to
tell what the back of that also
well if you want to compare you know
tomato tomato here
when you fought king velazquez on fox
where'd you hit him yeah around here
right yep around the back
is that dirty no [ __ ] happens man yeah
people move when the bullets are live
and they're flying
[ __ ] happens guys can't control it you
move yeah so when you got the biggest
knockout career and became the world
champion of ufc on one of the biggest
cards ever where'd you hit him um
yeah
that's a tough one that's like that's
not the same as like fence grabs and
yeah
i doubt he's
going for the back of the head
he's just throwing yeah he's just
throwing it just lands chaos that's a
tough slam on the back head but what's
the final
shot that's always the front of the head
always yeah he's not getting shot at the
back of the head and the first shot is
the one that gets them messed up yes
yeah you should be mad that you got hit
in the first place
all right so
jake paul versus anna's versus anderson
silva apparently it's targeted for
october 29th on showtime and then i
guess anderson got licensed in arizona
it might be in arizona that'd be sick
yeah
yeah shout out to jake paul for having
the balls fight out of all the guys that
he fought anderson silva
hands down not even remotely close
is the best boxer he's ever faced and
silva recently beat
julio chavez jr who is 53 multi world
champion i don't give a [ __ ] if hula
chevas jr barely trained for that he
grew up he when he came out he was
[ __ ] shadow boxing yeah think of his
dad the biggest
baddest most famous mexican period of
all time that's your [ __ ] dad he beat
that guy's son
you know yeah the answer came [ __ ]
boxing way older it's a tough fight for
jake
so for the naysayers if you if dude if
he starches anderson you got to stop
if he starts his anderson or stop the
haters
you have to give him some credit of
course
at some point you got to give it up at
some point the hate i get but at some
point this one you got to stop a little
bit you have to if he starches him like
in the second round like uppercut out
cold it's like kicking bucks you got him
give him credit dude
he's not a boxer though
that's not a boxer
that's not boxer you should see me at
[ __ ] twitter fitness the way i hit
the bag
so he's opening jake paul's opening as a
bit of a favorite that's insane yeah
minus 135. yeah that that's the better
is just trying to get money in line
they're just trying to get movement
that's all it is dude speed that you've
seen how you said like people are going
in from nate diaz you know we just
checked the odds earlier it was like
minus 1100 for comsat how's that and now
it's at nine something hold on let me
refresh this
yeah it's not minus 9.75 now and nate
diaz is plus 675 now within a matter of
minutes yeah the way the lions moves
like the most famous guy
if he's a big underdog gets a lot of
movement on it
crazy crazy i wanted to uh bet on nate
too just still good plus six seven five
you know put a hundred and one six 375
bucks not a bad bet and then if you look
at the prop that's like when you know
past three
no nadia has to win via tko or
submission like you're making some money
man yeah it's not bad parlay past nate
isn't beating him under three rounds so
if it's past three and an hd's win
you're making some money that's a good
bet
that's not that
you know the likelihood of that
happening not good but if he's gonna win
it that's how it goes down yeah third
fourth really fourth fifth round is
right if nate diaz were to win and it's
a hail mary it's cu bus versus michigan
the [ __ ] hell miracle
but that would happen later in the round
and nate's so durable i always fights
that goal that even with the jorge
mozzarella i know he was getting his ass
kicked in his ass
but
later on he's still gonna i think he
could potentially yeah yeah that's why
you'd put some money on if you wanna
make some money now
harms that stock compared to mazda is
different i'm [ __ ] beat yup man
yeah just seen it past two rounds social
power yeah it's given me a problem yeah
and gilbert
gilbert burns is an amazing what
submission artist but he's still
yeah yeah had his hands full so
okay so this is uh jake paul responding
to dave dana white so danielle did a
post fight press conference and said
don't ask me about jake paul anymore and
i'll just play the video
uh well yeah good what's up go ahead
okay stop asking me about jake paul you
guys i i don't give a [ __ ] what jake
paul does i know you love this [ __ ] and
i know it gives you clicks but come on
the guy has nothing to do with my
business he doesn't fight for me he's
not even in the same [ __ ] sport as me
i i don't want to talk about him anymore
it's
i don't care
i'm with dana on this too because all
he's doing is building up jake paul's
fight which of course
dana has nothing to do with it so dan's
like man you want to talk about someone
in my company fire away but to keep
asking about jake paul and get the
clicks and that's honestly because jake
paul that's what's going to get the most
views regardless if he's in your
business or not i'm with dana's like
dude no no i'm trying to make money on
my fighters yeah that guy has nothing to
do with us
you guys are just doing for clicks and
silva doesn't work for me jake paul
doesn't work for me quit [ __ ] asking
me i'm with dana on this i hear you yeah
yeah so this is what jake paul responded
sounds like an ex who still isn't able
to get over you why so angry turning red
he does turn red to all mma media you
can ask me anything you want that's your
job and i respect it yeah because it's
good for jake bad for dana yeah and by
the way when he did this video you can
he edited it on the very end it's a
subtle edit but watch
look at his face
oh my god just so funny just starts
getting red red really good tomato it's
so funny yeah you don't [ __ ] with these
young kids on [ __ ] social media man
they're too good at it yes they are okay
we talked about darren till not too long
ago hopefully hoping he was doing well
so apparently in july end of july he was
arrested for a dui in uh i think
stockholm yeah i stuck him yeah tell you
what if i was that guy drinking be the
last thing i'd be doing i'd be focused
on just getting back
yeah uh the one-time worldwide title
channel was usually for drunk driving
till's arrest took place on july 31st
wow driving at a high speed in central
stockholm near vagastan and one was
right in the passenger seat with till
and allegedly told please he was the one
driving till originally denied the
allegations but soon after admitting he
was indeed the case
two was labeled noticeably intoxicated
by the police and claimed his breath
test rock had to be three times higher
than the legal limit until accepted to
pounce the order well yeah so hopefully
he's doing well now
but that does suck
yeah three times mentally there's
something going on there something's
going on yes
okay so this is pretty crazy
there was a bkfc over the weekend
and this girl who used to be a lingerie
football player
you know you've seen that before right
oh yeah yeah
so apparently she uh
this is i don't know if this is her
first fight but she she won her fight in
bkfc and then she flashed one of her
boobies
you ever seen the coach in lingerie
football takes it way too serious thank
you
he's like it's covered too rebecca you
piece of [ __ ]
it's like hey
we're getting paid 70 dollars
some of them never got paid you know by
the way some never just i can't imagine
yeah they're like eight games in the
season like hey are we gonna get paid
like it's coming be cool
i can't imagine like even going to one
of those things unless you're like drunk
i don't know yeah there's not enough
alcohol in the world
all right so i'll show you this real
quick
fighting championship ty emery
yeah her name's ty emery so she just
flashed the audience one of her hits
yeah and this is her by the way i saw it
oh wow yeah
i'm not mad at that she's not yeah give
him a show
that's running lingerie football
that league was so ridiculous
yeah who actually just but that's
and they're like lacrosse helmets it's a
nightmare wow
okay um big boy fight news covered this
is just one girl built like ricky
williams just hand off to him she just
[ __ ] demolish them the thing is i
don't think they look like that they
have to look pretty hot you know oh yeah
but some words i mean are they muscular
okay yeah
all right
so yeah thick boy fight news covered
this already but so sean strickland's
out of his fight with janet jarrod
cannon here that's a bummer and it's
because of uh him punching someone in
the face and then the tooth
hit his hand is he on the street finger
no no uh training
and then it just it got infected it was
nasty so
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened i
think the
camp was going really [ __ ] good i had
a hard spa on thursday
i woke up friday and i was like hey you
know my my fingers were sore and then
throughout the day i was like my finger
as [ __ ] so i went to the hospital
turns out i have a really bad infection
from a tooth
uh yeah they're gonna cut me open drain
it out and
[ __ ] man i shouldn't went to college
guys i don't [ __ ] know i'll be out
for like three weeks though so
that's [ __ ] life right
guys
even if you went to college unless
you're becoming a doctor they're not
gonna tell you what that is yeah so
that's the thing in a lot of uh street
fights this happens guys all the time so
this hit somebody in the in the face
right and the like kid a tooth or like
the bottom tooth and your mouth has so
much bacteria in it it gets into their
blood you're [ __ ]
yeah so your mouth is dirty as [ __ ] so
when people get in street fights happens
more times than you think
of course that's his finger right there
looks so nasty yeah it sucks he's out of
the fight
yeah i remember getting into like one
fight where
i did well i was happy about myself and
then afterwards i remember spitting
blood
and then i
looked inside my lip
everything inside my lip from the top
and the bottom was all shut up yeah and
the healing process with that was
[ __ ] crazy dude yeah brutal
yeah street fighting is not smart no
okay so luke rockhold said on his
instagram that you know before he said
he retired he officially retired but he
said he might actually come back i think
you guys talked about this on fight
companion too yeah i don't think he
should so he said but he wants to give
him his self time to like you know
recover his body at his age what he's
done you know
yeah the injuries but yeah
i i thought it was a great send off even
though he lost he lost a big time guy
if you want to do one against not a top
five guy i'd be open to it better than
that you know
who's drinking this top [ __ ] five
guys
that'd be super fun yeah
that fight more makes more sense he has
a better chance to win that fight than
paul costa
that'd be fun
it's a good idea case
after what two three years come back
fully healthy maybe a year
no you can't get healthy a year probably
just stopped a year yeah i know about
years during that five days you can't
get fully healthy
yeah a year
i think you mentioned like two or three
years but yeah
yeah
all right so chelsea you know he says a
lot of stuff on his podcast he said that
um leon edwards won the kamar uzman
fight by cheating mm-hmm i guess he
grabbed the fence multiple times and the
ref you know
stopped or just said like you know
didn't give didn't take a point off but
just like i said yeah stop stop stop
chill doing for the views i know dude i
know so
so this helen yee you know helen yee
yeah i love her awesome reporter yeah so
she interviewed her dean and apparently
um
hold on so this is what chill said leon
was frustrated position had no way of
position to extent that he cheated
repeatedly not once non-accident not the
ref didn't see it the ref broke that act
five or six times that's what he's chill
saying and then um this is what
this herb is saying yeah burp says fence
grabs a very difficult thing to deal
with in the sport because it's a natural
reaction yeah but it's literally the
number one thing to tell you not to do
yeah it's gonna happen but to deduct the
point so let's take a look at what point
deduction means in sport what does a
point deduction mean what's the most
common score that goes to the car 2928
so that means we have one point sport
for a majority of fights that happen
that go to the cars 20 29 20 is the most
common score okay and then here so when
you take a point that means you've taken
a win
you have
but the reason you would take a point is
because then someone didn't use the cage
to get to their feet yeah
which if he couldn't use the cage he's
gonna stay down that guy's definitely
gonna win the round but if he uses the
cage and can get to his feet that gives
him the ability to win the round so you
take a point
that's why i think this is interesting
because i i hear what chill's saying and
i hear what i'm a champion yeah exactly
you're taking a point yeah listen i
groin kick i poke i don't like warnings
yeah a warning for
to grab the fence i can see if you're
like if you get hit you're falling back
or you you put fingers in to kind of get
up and like whoa dude and you're like oh
[ __ ] it's just an actual reaction yeah
fence grabbing i i agree with a warning
the first time
i didn't see it five or six times but
chael's usually pretty spot-on and stuff
five or six times you gotta take a point
if it happened that yeah you have to
so he says when you take a point that
means you've taken a win it's not like
other sports where you have 12 rounds
you take a point it's much stiffer
punishment and majority of the fights
that happen when you've taken a point
you've taken a win not true uh to have
that balance there the point that grab
needs to certainly affect the fight will
how do you know that if you didn't grab
that fight exactly kamara wouldn't
finish them down yeah exactly that way
it doesn't wear them out more where you
can't throw a head cake it's insane
and and i think herb has like one or two
fights which
those things are judgmental you're gonna
say okay how many times does this happen
is the other fouls or hey even this one
time this guys has spent a lot of energy
i can't rebuild the position any other
way and so i'm going to choose not to
give a warning at this time or take a
point that's insane yeah i don't like
that either yeah
to me it's going to be such a gray area
it should be very black and white i poke
groin kick fence grab i'll take a point
fence grab is the only one you can see
given a tad warning if it's just a
natural reaction
over
over one time it's just your thing
you're doing it as an advantage can't
just be a natural reaction all the
[ __ ] time if you're falling you kind
of like do this
but if you're doing that constantly if
you're if it's like the guys on top
being like mound or something or like a
half guard and you're grabbing the cage
it pull yourself up i mean that's a
calculated move
point taken yeah
all right chill also said that uh conor
mcgregor's championship run is over but
conor doesn't know about it yet
i mean most likely yeah i think you
wouldn't agree with the yeah what he
said here championship run is over
that's true that's mean conor did not
come out and tell you guys because he's
not aware of it no no no fighters i say
connor's championship time is done conor
mcgregor's record setting isn't conor
mcgregor's live gate is not done carmel
gray's pay-per-view potential these
things are not done this time in the
spotlight's time is the main event these
are not done at all agree 100 percent
and also if i'm his team i don't
have him take this year off where he's
getting sucked off on his yacht and
gochi pajamas and him fight you know for
a title you have invited tony ferguson
or something like that you don't throw
him the [ __ ] top one or two guys that
to me that's just bad management you
know get him a win get you know get him
get him his bearing back get his
confidence back and then you can shoot
for that stuff but to take this much
time off and getting sucked off on your
boat and then come in and fight the
number one guy in the world is
insane to me insane they're doing a
disservice and also cuts the
the shelf life on him being a big
pay-per-view star him being the biggest
number one gate because he keeps losing
if he gets bad and he's competing
against he's really you know savages all
the [ __ ] time with these long laughs
terrible business plan
depend what mcgregor wants to do
does girls make the most money possible
in short span of time all right fight
charles olivier yeah i'm guessing that's
what he wants to do all right yeah
and even coming back from that freaking
leg break to throw a leg kick after that
no i don't yeah i don't know
all right so
vanilla silva i thought he was already
retired but i guess not but he he
officially retired and now his son's
fighting in mma and he's gonna just help
him out it's his son in the middle thor
sylvia
damn thor thor
he has one win is it jay shop
with when he grows up zillion j shop
with a [ __ ] jerry curl
i mean i'm good for him i'll never
forget man when and or when vanderbilt
got his face done he says because of
scar tissue just straight up got a face
he looks completely different and i was
invasive songs like oh holy [ __ ]
he didn't just get the scar tissue you
went
full
caitlyn janna yeah he looks so different
i mean completely different guy i get it
though
he looks like my dad
oh wait let me see how far this thing
isn't
so there was um
here it is you said the face thing so it
reminded me of justin gates you know
just the issue had his nose done because
he had like a bad deviated symptom yeah
he's been waiting to get it done for a
while yeah so he had it done and
remember we brought this article a while
ago but
this is rafael fazeev getting his nose
done as well that's why he wants to like
try to get a fight with justin gaichi
because they both oh my god that's such
a good fight great fight yeah but i'd
list so i saw this post by justin gaichi
on august 20th which is after he got a
surgery but he sounds just the same
oh how long guys i'm out here at ufc 278
i'm in between some meet and greets
right now
just wanted to jump on tell you how to
make some money click on my bio click
the link in my box because no sounds
like it's not fixed it might take some
time though too does it yeah they do
take a while so you did the same well no
you didn't do that i you know i had the
same surgery you did yeah both of them
has the exact same thing takes a while
okay
not only does it take a while but it's
not like it you're a hundred percent
like you don't come back to hundo if you
think it's gonna be like life-changing
no you're out of your [ __ ] mind okay
so it helps a little bit then yeah and
sometimes didn't help at all
that sucks yeah
i didn't yeah but you delete you can't
hear us when he talks he can't hear it
but with justin you can hear it yeah
like yeah
a little bit
i'm a mouth breather
all right so this is uh daniel cormier
you know him and jorge mosbidal have
been going on um on social media yeah
and he said it was
he thought it was
yeah so this is uh daniel cormier saying
what uh jorge needs to do to get to the
to the belt
well how does jorge mas with all get to
a title fight one
you got to fight gilbert burns right now
you got to accept that fight
i don't know if you've been offered the
fight i don't know if the legal issues
are keeping you from taking the fight it
is the gilbert burns is out there saying
that the fight's been offered he's out
there saying publicly that
it's just on you now and i know jorge
mazdaw's a street dude
from miami and does not run from a fight
but if you want that title fight you got
to fight dorino right now
and you got to win
but you also got to do one more thing
you got to fight him
before the uzman edwards rematch is
announced the trilogy
you got to be going in the right
direction by the time that fight gets
announced so that if given the
opportunity
you can capitalize on the chance just
like you did in the first title fight
yeah he's right
yeah he's not speaking anything
okay um so remember drake
made a post like he he replied to uh
he won all this money he's gonna buy him
rolex's patty pinball yeah so i saw this
so apparently he got the rolex right so
the article here says uh drake keeps his
promise and gives patti pemblet a rolex
watch worth over 50 thousand dollars
which watch did he give him though i
mean this rolex i can't tell what it is
though
the datejust
but i mean it's 50k over 50k yeah
so
this is patti pimbler
nice one for that today thank you very
much he said he'd give us a roll
actually he's gone as well
you would have been able to get us a
better watch if you were the bet with
basketball he would have got more money
but thank you very much really
appreciate that
that's cool that's cool but the thing i
noticed is like so he got us a watch
because i remember the other articles
showed that i thought they both get
older exactly i thought molly mccann
told molly too
y'all share this
saturday monday wednesday friday that's
yours as far as i know one tuesday
thursday saturday exactly so just one
watch as far as i know unless someone
else knows anything different yeah yeah
i thought you didn't have to do it but
that's cool he did it yeah
but i mean i think cool if he got about
daytona or something like that but
oh anyways but yeah so he did promise
molly too but i didn't see anything with
molly
so this is crazy uh this is dominic
reyes next to alex bahia who's gonna
fight izzy and dude look at the size of
alex brahim he's jacked and dominic is
light heavy yeah
all right
insane and also this i'll say this if
you would have put um jesus christ yeah
he weighs 226 right now and he's percent
body fat yep that cuts can be tough and
he's six four that cuts they kiss me
tough
really tough
really really tough and jon jones said
this
be careful not to show izzy too much
champ i honestly don't think it will
matter though
he goes it's yours and then he goes
loving that shot i guess from
yeah
yeah i i think it's crazy to count is he
out here here's the thing if izzy took a
picture to don mcgregor's you guys would
be blown away is he i'm telling i've
been yeah next to you you've been around
everybody is he's a [ __ ] big dude
they're both big so if you think because
pierre showing this off that he's big as
dominic reyes is like some
crazy advantage it's not it's not
it's crazy you guys are counting out is
he i mean who's counting them out a lot
of people i have five thousand dollars
on it with brian counts dumbass
did you you weren't you had a dominique
raise on the show too right or am i
tripping that i'm on you've put them on
so you've seen the different size
between izzy and and
is thin and tall oh yeah i mean is he's
big dude man yeah that's why i like izzy
at light heavyweight if he wants to if
he beats biera i like him out light
heavyweight against yuri now if it's a
glover yawn all right if guys is gonna
grapple and use their huge size
advantage then yeah no i don't like that
but fury's a champ or there's a striker
champ i like him
all righty uh
your boy ben rothwell his first fight in
the kfc will be against uh
well it's gonna be october 1st and it's
going to be against a guy named bobo
oben or something like that it's three
and three yeah bobo o'bannon that's
exactly how i think he was gonna work
look at the air behind him exhausted
yeah that's me in four years look at him
that's me in four years if i could grow
that beard make him look exactly the
same and grow your hair
yeah so he lost alan belcher who ellen
belcher now is like so savage yeah
but yeah that's his first fight
good luck good luck fighting ben
rothwell and bare knuckle i know i feel
like ben is gonna destroy him ben's
gonna clean the house
so uh nate diaz apparently applied for a
promoter's license and his promotion is
gonna be called real fight inc it's
really interesting to see once he gets
behind you know the scenes and he's a
suit and tie how he runs his business
compared to dana he might understand a
lot more after that yeah
once it's like a business and you're
looking at numbers and you know how much
your overhead is and paying the guys and
you know
[ __ ]
covering their medical bills like it's a
lot man yeah a lot of overhead and
they're like holy [ __ ] i'm only taking
home 10 grand for all this [ __ ] you know
and then the fight fighter payout should
be instinct
it will be interesting because everyone
you know listen there's been a lot of
people for nate diaz that we know we're
about fighter pay and we treat fighters
right cool cool cool how deflection go
for you you know how do these other
leagues go for it
you can't do it and make it make a
profit it's tough yeah
yep
all right so friend of the show mcdojo
yeah
all right so he had this uh
it's a long thing but so he put this
video up about a guy that was an mma
fighter who now wants to
identify as a woman oh yeah with a beard
mm-hmm
because he had all these different
charges like sexual sexual assault
charges you know
sexual violence all sorts of stuff but
then he wants to get a leaner sentence
by identifying as a woman
that's where we're living man yeah and
that's the guy right there his his
name's jody matthew burke
he looks like an offender
and he says the reason why he lashed out
so many times is because he always felt
like he was you know and he's
struggling with that sure so yeah it's
pretty lame yeah yeah
that giant freaking cassio
he-man watch and the beard begs to
differ
yeah all right also don't wear that
watch
i used to wear like really big watches
and i uh i still have them but i don't
know yeah yeah like the big jacobson
code watches they're invicta they're
called oh yeah yeah those are disgusting
it was orange too i just thought this
was funny this is uh floyd mayweather
just skating and he actually looks like
he's a good skater he's a really good
skater
yeah i would play the music but we can't
do that oh man yeah
maybe a little snippet
[Music]
but he's actually really good yeah
there's nothing better than some little
dude when i was at kidman's gate city
aurora colorado off colfax there oh
mississippi and colfax great time and we
would go there skate you'd fall in front
of the girl you had a crush on super
embarrassing eating funnel cakes there's
arcades at the back
wow the brown roller blades and i
couldn't skate like this i could go
backwards though for a little bit
you get low with it
casey would destroy on this you know
casey was basically a professional
skater
really like he was about to get
sponsored rollerblade yeah that's good
there's a bunch of
there's a bunch of videos online too
he's so good really so show me a video i
have no clue
professional uh rollerblading how do i
find her casey
quesadilla
quesadilla
quesadilla
work that was your your nickname was
quesadilla there you go
dude like legit amazing watches
this crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna just mute this music real
quick just in case i mean and and
rollerblading was life
dude look at this holy [ __ ]
what do you mean
he has tats of rollerblades on his feet
what uh what brand did you roll with uh
what brand did you blade with
a bunch uh right now
uh usd
hell yeah usd
dude dude he was legit this was like
your thing
yeah oh this is recent
oh you're still you're still
rollerblading all the time i'm still
very good
i was gonna say i thought you just got
how the [ __ ] you have all this time you
have golf that's at venice high right
there
frowned upon doing the high schools
wow you got to do this you never want to
you never want to do the uh
the skateboard
rollerblades and what are we going to do
with it dude
this is freaking insane no man that's
not the [ __ ] i did bro
i'm talking i had the four wheels you
know two up front two at the back brown
leather ice skating red laces or white
laces
i was there for the chicks and funnel
cakes man
but yeah he was
just or he is legit
this case he's rollerblading
yeah now rollerblading he might as well
have monkey pox down venice you know
what i'm saying
yeah you're [ __ ] good super good
jesus chill man
look at this [ __ ]
and did you grow up rollerblading
oh that makes
sense that doesn't do you want to do the
full ice hockey huh
no
yeah i feel you it's kind of crazy when
you learn about
i thought i knew these guys but then you
dig a little deeper i had no idea you
could pull up your ass
yeah i thought he was abs yeah i'm
surprised you're not like freaking
like tony hawk level as far as the
people he sponsors you know what i'm
saying
skateboard wise anyways yeah you're
going some competitions man are there
rollerblading competitions like street
comps like x games and [ __ ] never
thought about that
okay jesus christ competitive
rollerblader
wow and now he is behind the cameras
behind the camera is golfing all the
time man wow good for you man
okay so tyson fury has been on his
instagram doing a lot of different
things this is one of them he's calling
out usyk
you say you want the wbc oh we watch
this on fighting
yeah it is held by gypsies it's held by
the gypsy king
and it's held tightly grasped tight on
all the roads leads to a seven-foot beam
off that will absolutely destroy you
that is retired
exactly so he did this and then he
called out joshua just i think very
recently
here
three hours ago
hey tyson fury here aka the gypsy king
the wbc heavyweight champion of the
world she looks in shape too um
i think you've all are that i'm gonna be
fighting uh soon within the next few
months and
i think that before i announce an
opponent that i
need to do this just in case
anthony joshua i know you've just lost a
fight to usa and you doubt us at the
moment
um
and i'd like to give you an opportunity
to fight me for the wbc championship of
the world i don't know in the old
championship
in the next few months you're coming off
a 12-round fight so your match fit
you're ready um i'm giving you a few
months notice uh if you're interested i
bet joshua take it
i think he's doing it because if he
doesn't do it we'll never see joshua
fury
that's why he's doing it because it
especially out in the uk that everybody
wants that fight everybody's just
yearning for that fight so he's like
might as well get out now you have that
you have usakia francis
yeah you're getting three fights out of
fear i bet things out and he can't
retire without fighting joshua
especially for the uk fans it sucks that
joshua's on the skid but he'll still be
a great fighter [ __ ] money yeah
and then ingano
i think he kind of yeah you touched on
this but ingano basically says
he wants to do boxing and
mma but he says he has to have his
boxing in there
so they're asking about fury's like it
doesn't doesn't matter if it's fury or
not but i have to do boxes that's what
i'm saying i think he could get a big
dog in like a wilder or
even a ruiz or something like that even
though ruiz not a huge name but you get
like a wilder i think if joshua let's
say he fought fury the next by december
i think you get a joshua too especially
if joshua loses josh would do it for
money out too yeah but yeah the fury one
seems to be kind of getting out of reach
here
all right so this has been making a lot
of
mma media news so mark zuckerberg he's
training in apparently you know i was
wrong he said he's obsessed with ufc
that's how i found about logan he trains
[ __ ] jitsu all the time i think i
think that's super cool because it
brings more light to the sport which i
mean i don't think people regular people
mainstream people that don't follow mma
they they now know that the ceo of
facebook is actually training that's
cool right does jiu-jitsu yeah it's very
cool robots are doing jiu-jitsu
all right so anyways when i saw this i
saw oh god is is is ufc on here oh yes
oh my god
oh my god you're just thirsty for the
likes but i mean everyone you'll see
combo's looking clean piece of soap then
connor yo [ __ ] awesome mark way to go
bro then rogan this is fantastic happy
to see this training looks solid too
no it doesn't i knew you would love this
i knew you would call it and then cody
okay respect to you bro you're doing the
damn thing you know i love you cody but
what are we doing here everybody pierrot
everyone everyone dude everyone you know
what this guy does on facebook guys do
you have any clue what this man does on
facebook
i suppress his information he's like
it's just the algorithm i have no idea
twitter does it worse robot
i need oh my volkanovsky you guys have a
little respect for yourselves vulkanasi
looks good
not bad zuckers
gilbert burns this is dope
todd glazer training is so fun rad to
see
adc
looking sharp ruka flames dave camarillo
yo you look fantastic
yeah looking better every day literally
uriah the triple threat
god damn it you guys
hey man
it's all good yeah at least he's trying
but it was funny to see all these like
really
do that this but it's just so thirsty
yeah there's some thirst in there but
his training partner is a guy named kai
wu i remember we had i don't know if we
actually i had it on one of the tabs for
current events for finding the kid but i
guess he was one of the guys that
uh
some white dude came into an asian
restaurant and started being a dick and
he like calmly like
you know made him like chill out mm-hmm
and then it made like headlines so
that's his training partner this guy was
kind of went viral for
the video
bringing more attention to the sport i
get it all the thirsty guys on there
though jesus it was kind of fun i knew
you would love that uh this is kind of
this is nothing big but so
zhang willie says the first time she's
ever gonna fight someone that's a
wrestler is now and it's carlos barza so
she wants to see how she does against
her
carla's respectful rival her up and down
experience very inspiring gives me power
to keep going crawl will be the first
wrestler i meet so i'm very interested
in progressing progress of exchange all
we got in arsenal my goal is to dominate
the show yeah yeah great fight for uh
zayn
and tough because carla's such a great
wrestler
so this is before the fight before ty
devasta fought sirogon but taitovasa
posted
pictures of
or screenshots of him and jon jones
talking on social media so oh because
taitovas came out was like i respect him
but i don't know what yeah the [ __ ] he
does exactly and so this is ty
ty says you sound off your head
i'd out party you two i reckon just
saying but yeah mary had a little lamp
too and i smoked her
i don't know whatever whatever bro when
you come back i'll still be around you
want to warm up lamb roast i'll be
waiting
then john puts good luck with your bear
company and then ty puts chairs with
sending somebody says i don't need it
you keep it ello stop writing
and then you put sweet you stop writing
and then eventually john blocked him
hilarious yeah
so
this is on ariel's show i think john's
the best fighter ever just how he fights
how he fights he probably is the best
fighter that ever stepped from the cage
but he's a [ __ ] yes i think he's a
[ __ ] and while i fight him he has to
want the girls to do it but i'd love to
win i'd love to fight him when i lose
i'm gonna go in there and have a swag if
i dink him i sink him didn't care i
think him that's a fair dinkum you know
what i mean he said he's not sure if
he's
like he might be scared of him but it
also makes him excited you know
to fight john john
and now
yeah john will be a knight yeah exactly
i can't believe john pays attention to
this [ __ ] he answers all the [ __ ] he's
been through
um this is a quick one so this is before
the fight as well oh i know he paid for
his own fit yeah because he doesn't want
to sit and coach because he's too big he
says i get it yeah you know the ufc used
to fly stefan struve who's seven foot
coach no way and he used to fly from
amsterdam
and they were like and you know we had
the same address like it's a nightmare
we're trying to at least give him
business class do something he's like
nah if you want then you paid for it he
was seven foot tall flying like [ __ ]
that's insane southwest
group that's sea boarding pack can you
imagine southwest metro city yeah [ __ ]
that giraffe on the flight it's a
nightmare that'd be horrible yeah tai
tuvasa deserves it yeah he says he
always pays for his own flights he's
like yeah i'm at a level i'll just pay
for my own [ __ ] that's cool but it
sucks that they called ufc reimbursed
him think how much money they made off
them off these papers these knockouts
come on dude i'll leave reimburse half
or something that'd be [ __ ] cool man
or
give them the the money that you're
gonna pay for for his flight yeah so it
doesn't hurt as bad
but come from [ __ ] australia new
zealand to america to paris yeah our
flight was insane man remember how long
it took nuts yeah i just got offered to
play australia next year
last thing about flights i'm like [ __ ]
dude dude you gotta do it yeah crowds
are so amazing yeah
okay um
so this i thought was funny there's two
different things i want to show you here
so first one first one's this this is
dana white you know we already knew this
we talked about it before dana white not
liking the fact that hulu did this on
yeah i know i don't think anybody in the
fight game likes it so mike tyson didn't
you know he didn't sign off on it and
then they wanted to pay dana a lot of
money to promote it
right so this he was we're about to do a
deal blah blah
he squashed the deal after he knew that
mike tyson didn't approve of it and he
goes so i killed the deal told him it
was over
that i killed it and we won't be
promoting that show for hulu
so i watched the fights
on over the weekend
the se fights all the way again oh
there's a promotion
i'll show you right here first that's
right i would dude i'm go
because while we're doing five minutes i
saw an ad from like exactly so i saw
this i was like oh crap but but yeah i
bet you this isn't dana i know it's easy
i assume it's cs it is like we'll do the
deal we'll take the money we don't give
a [ __ ] about mike tyson but dana
was it because they were going to run it
like during the ufc and probably have it
on the mats and days like that ain't
happening on my watch but the espn's
like oh very cool well mickey mouse
doesn't give a [ __ ] about mike tyson and
mickey mouse is mickey mouse so it was a
ufc show but they did promote it or i
guess espn promoted it so it was just
funny
i bet mike's like what the [ __ ] i know
dude
especially he's watching he probably
licked like a poisonous frog and he's
like what the [ __ ] is happening right
now yeah that's not data that's the espn
we'll just take all the money it happens
it happens and then we give you nothing
all right so there's that and also i
recorded this too because i
so i don't know if you saw it as the
quinones fight he's a mexican fighter
right and
they had a
the french translator was there for
everything but they didn't bring a
mexican or sorry a spanish translator in
there so i just i posted this video on
my instagram story
[Music]
[Music]
i'll tell you what english is tough
enough sure as [ __ ] don't speak french
oh dude
but i had so many people replying like
dude it's for the french audience i'm
like yeah i know the french guys for the
french artists but they didn't bring a
spanish translator they've done both
i guarantee you there's a guy who speaks
french and spanish they're yeah they
should they didn't think about it yeah
so it was just funny that i saw this his
face he's all i don't know bisping's
like put some
mic in front of you because i have no
[ __ ] glue
that's players yeah
all right let's oh this is so jacked up
so this is in russia
so this guy his name is zuluzino he's
about to submit this guy named
peter ramon kevich and watch what
happens
it looks like a grizzly bear
he stood him up it's probably
[Music]
what are you trying to do
so they stopped him from getting his
camera he was literally about to snap
his [ __ ] shoulder off and the ref
went well what are you doing dude
exactly how dare you try and submit a
guy stop standing get kicked in the face
real quick and he got knocked out after
that he looks like a giant grizzly bear
he looks like one of the older older ufc
fighters like ufc yeah yeah yeah with
the pants and [ __ ] that's russia
yeah is that it um that's pretty much it
let me see here yeah that's pretty much
it all right kids hope you guys enjoyed
the show lots going on enjoy ufc 279
this weekend your main event hamzat and
nate diaz co-main event uh
you got the leach vs tony ferguson kevin
holland daniel rodriguez great freaking
card it's gonna be a fun one a lot of
mystery going on as i explained earlier
breaking down ufc 279 i will be watching
the green room in appleton wisconsin
appleton wisconsin you're up baby think
boy tour is coming this thursday friday
saturday in appleton wisconsin um
i have one show shop and friends la you
all saw the last show chris dalia
theovan david spade michael rapport we
bring in heat we're back september 13th
one night only one show 8 p.m hollywood
improv so come get some la and then back
on the tour ontario california my
favorite clubs ontario improv september
15th through the 17th then i end
september's tour dates in boston well my
favorite place on earth my son's name
boston for that matter uh boston is
september 29th through october 1st at
laugh boston that bad [ __ ] about to
sell out so get your tickets right now
at thickboy.com and they just added san
jose and salt lake city in october so
get you some uh the hat you see me
rocking right now there might be a few
left this is the mike stud thick boy
collection that's on mike studs website
the mike stud uh save a horse ride a
thick boy collab with myself
um on his website it's sold out but
they're gonna restock them very soon but
then also with mine the mike stud save a
horseradish thick boy shirt and hat is
available only on tour in person so i
will have them with me in person on tour
appleton ontario boston europe
thickboy.com see you guys soon thanks
for watching be nice to each other like
subscribe do all that shenanigans i just
launched a new youtube channel it's the
bren shop comedy channel so thick boys
just for the fight news and fight
related stuff and then the bread and
shop is all stand up you get every week
new stand-up material from green room
diaries which i write the day i come
into the freaking city you get clips
from both of my specials you get uh
behind the scenes stuff you're getting
new clips new videos all
freaking weekend long man so um yeah i
hope you enjoy it go like subscribe to
that channel as well for all my stand up
love you guys be nice to each other
appleton c this weekend i'm out